voilà donc madame la ministre
nous poursuivons notre travaux avec
votre audition nous venons d'entendre
successivement Cécile Duflot et Sylvia
Pinel et la semaine dernière nous avons
déjà entendu François de Rugy et
Ségolène Royal donc vous avez été
vice-présidente de la Région
Île-de-France en charge du logement de
2010 à 2015 puis ministre du logement et
de l'habitat durable de 2016 à 2017 et
vous êtes depuis 2020 présidente de
l'Union sociale pour l'habitat je
précise que c'est aujourd'hui en votre
qualité d'anciennes ministres que nous
vous recevons et je suis convaincu que
vous aurez aussi des choses à nous dire
en matière de rénovation énergétique
depuis que vous avez votre mandat de
présidente de l'USH votre passage au
gouvernement a été marqué par la mise en
application de la loi de transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte
du 17 août 2015 la profondissement de
certaines de ces mesures et le
développement d'expérimentation dans le
domaine de la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments notamment les territoires à
énergie positive et le label énergie
positive et rééducation réduction de
carbone je souhaite que vous puissiez
nous éclairer sur le bilan que vous
tirez de votre expérience notamment dans
l'application de la loi transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte et
le lancement de ces différentes
expérimentations dont je viens de parler
quel verrou avez-vous identifié quels
sont vos motifs de satisfaction et vous
regrets c'est toutefois vous en avez
souhaitez-vous souhaitez-vous allier
plus loin quels sont les obstacles que
vous avez rencontré dans cette
entreprise est-ce qu'un ministre de
plein exercice a été un atout ou à
présenter des difficultés pour la
avec la ministre chargée de l'écologie
et de l'énergie les exigences en matière
de sobriété énergétique imposée par
l'accord de Paris et inscrit dans la
stratégie nationale bas carbone exigée
une rénovation profonde du bâtiment en
France c'était l'objectif de la loi pour
la croissance verte qui apparaît
aujourd'hui comme celle qui a fixé le
cadre et les principaux objectifs des
politiques menées à la manière les lois
énergies climat de 2019 et la loi plus
récente climat et résilience de 2021
venant l'approfondir mais aussi souvent
reportée certains objectifs
pourtant aujourd'hui le bâtiment demeure
un secteur particulièrement énergivore
et émetteur de gaz à effet de serre or
les objectifs de rénovation énergétique
que nous étions fixés notamment la
rénovation de 500 000 logements par an
ne sont toujours pas atteints c'est
pourquoi je voudrais également vous
inviter à nous faire partager votre
analyse et les raisons de cet échec quel
jugement portez-vous sur la politique
qui a été menée en matière de rénovation
énergétique depuis maintenant un peu
plus de 5 ans pensez-vous que celle-ci
nécessitait plus de continuité et de
constance par rapport aux outils déjà en
œuvre plutôt qu'une refonte des
dispositifs enfin avant de vous laisser
la parole pour répondre à ses premières
questions et pour un propos introductif
d'une quinzaine de minutes il me revient
de vous indiquer que cette
est diffusée en direct et en différé sur
le site internet du Sénat et que fera
l'objet d'un compte rendu publié je dois
également vous rappeler de façon très
formelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête serait
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 euros à 100000 euros d'amende
je vous invite donc madame la ministre a
prêté serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité et à lever la main
droite et à dire je mesure
voilà donc je vous laisse la parole pour
une quinzaine de minutes et ensuite
notre rapporteur bien sûr complétera et
vous posera un certain nombre de
questions ainsi qu'un certain nombre de
membres de la commission d'enquête qui
sont présents physiquement dans cette
salle madame la Présidente
et les sénateurs tout d'abord je vous
remercie pour cette audition puisque
c'est toujours intéressant d'avoir à
répondre devant les parlementaires du
passé et y compris comme vous
m'interrogez dessus du bilan qu'on fait
des années passées dans l'exercice
ministériel même si évidemment c'est un
bilan très subjectif peut-être un peu
plus politique que technique mais en
tout cas je vous ferai part de mes de
mes points de vue par ailleurs madame la
Présidente j'ai cru comprendre que je
serais auditionné plus tard en tant que
présidente de l'Union sociale pour
l'habitat vous me le confirmerez donc
c'est vrai que je vais plutôt la
répondre plutôt en tant que ministre
même si j'ai des points de vue qui ne
sont pas différents de mes fonctions
actuelles comme de mes fonctions passées
mais voilà sauf si vous souhaitez qu'à
un moment je revienne très
particulièrement sur des questions liées
au logement social
peut-être pour revenir sur le le
contexte de l'enjeu et y compris les
questions que vous posez et qui sont
tout à fait légitimes sur la difficulté
sur le pourquoi les quels sont les
raisons de d'une politique sur la
rénovation qui semble être en échec je
pense que déjà il faut bien se rendre
compte que c'est la politique la plus
difficile en matière de logement parce
qu'on s'attaque au stock on s'attaque au
stock donc un volume de bâti dans
l'ensemble de son hétérogénéité
collectif comme individuel bâtiments
récents comme bâtiment extrêmement
ancien en plus dans un pays où la le
poids du bâtiment ancien d'avant la
Première Guerre mondiale reste important
à ce qui n'est pas exactement la même
chose si vous comparez avec d'autres
pays européens et puis s'attaquer au
stock ça veut dire que on s'attaque donc
au logement existant et donc on
s'attaque à la vie des gens et je crois
que ça explique aussi une des
difficultés qui est que
vous rentrez dans la vie de particulier
à la à l'aune de ces questions sur la
réhabilitation et ce qui veut dire aussi
que même si évidemment il y a une partie
des logements détenus par des bailleurs
sociaux donc des propriétaires massives
des foncières mais beaucoup de logements
sont devenus par les particuliers ça
veut dire il faudrait un accompagnement
énorme pour pouvoir faire quelque chose
avec eux et ça explique aussi la
difficulté
et parfois l'échec de certaines
politiques
il me semble il me semble important de
d'y répondre parce que c'est vrai qu'on
porte beaucoup d'attention sur les
enjeux de production nouvelles sur les
enjeux de la crise du logement mais
traiter le stock de logements existant
pose évidemment des questions bien plus
difficiles quel bilan je peux faire de
mon passage alors au gouvernement tout
d'abord je pense important de le
contextualiser parce que moi je suis
arrivée en fin de mandat et y compris en
étant nommé en 2016 je savais que mon
mandat n'irait de toute façon pas plus
loin que la fin du mandat du Président
de la République donc mon équipe et
moi-même avions et c'était d'ailleurs la
volonté du gouvernement à l'époque des
objectifs très clairs qui étaient
l'application des textes de loi et
notamment la publication des décrets
d'applications alors vous avez parlé de
la loi de la transition énergétique pour
la croissance verte mais il y avait
aussi la loi alur quand je suis arrivé
il y avait plus de 200 décrits encore à
prendre et c'est vrai que nous avons
cherché à mettre en application un
certain nombre de ces textes mais aussi
répondre d'ailleurs à des missions
d'information qui étaient déjà en cours
sur cette Aixe de loi ce qui explique
aussi que j'ai certes réorienté
certaines politiques mais je n'avais pas
exactement le même positionnement que
les ministres que les ministres
passaient même si j'ai par ailleurs
publié enfin travailler un autre texte
de loi qui a été soyé mais qui était pas
sur les mêmes sur les mêmes sujets
et par ailleurs en tout cas au moment où
j'arrive au gouvernement on a évidemment
les enjeux de rénovation mais on a aussi
d'autres préoccupations et qui sont
évidemment le soutien la production
nouvelle de logement qui était vraiment
le cœur de la politique de l'époque
logement privé comme logement sociaux
les radication de l'habitat insalubre
et vous le savez madame lassenasie tout
était rapporteur de mon texte de loi
j'ai échoué puisqu'en fait on voulait
prendre une ordonnance sur le sujet et
que elle n'a pas été prise et ça ça a
été fait plus tard dans le quinquennat
suivant c'est un enjeu extrêmement fort
toute la question en fait de la
précarité énergétique et qui est pas
seulement liée à la rénovation mais qui
était vraiment de travailler sur les
publics les plus en difficulté et puis
une volonté aussi de moderniser la
profession parce qu'on était un stade
aussi on avait des tas d'enjeux sur les
garanties autour de la profession dans
le bâtiment des enjeux de cartes
professionnelles de fraude à l'emploi de
fraude à la TVA et vous le savez sur les
sujets particuliers de la mise en place
de la du label RGE et puis par ailleurs
lorsque j'étais ministre j'avais aussi
des enjeux extrêmement forts sur de la
mise en place de nouveaux dispositifs
l'encadrement des loyers le permis de
louer c'est des décrets que nous avons
pris début 2016 et aussi des
mobilisations sur des sujets locaux sur
lesquels le Premier ministre de l'époque
m'avait demandé de travailler beaucoup
la question de l'habitat insalubre et
indigne à Marseille et la revitalisation
du bassin minier avec notamment des
enjeux de rénovation extrêmement
importante mais qui était en soi des
politiques très fortes et qui n'étaient
pas d'ailleurs dans les dans les sujets
dont on va parler dont on va parler
après tout ça pour vous dire que
évidemment il y avait un enjeu très fort
sur la rénovation mais qu'il était
inscrit dans une politique logement plus
globale et après pour dire les choses
très franchement oui moi j'ai fait
partie d'un gouvernement qui afficher
ses objectifs qui a fixé des objectifs
de construction de logements de
production de logements sociaux et d'un
objectif de 500 000 rénovations avec
évidemment quand vous fixez un objectif
en tant que gouvernement vous mettez en
difficulté puisque vous donnez les
moyens à vos adversaires comme à vos
partenaires de dire vous ne les faites
pas oui mais au moins on avait un
objectif et je pense que c'est
extrêmement important justement de
travailler ainsi parce que même si un
objectif vous n'arrivez pas à
l'atteindre au moins vous en avez donné
un et vous dites que le qu'il est là
alors on l'a vu d'ailleurs sur la
question de la production de logements
sociaux de ne pas vouloir donner
d'objectifs on voit ce que ça donne
derrière mais c'est pareil pour la
rénovation assumez même si on n'y arrive
pas qu'il fallait faire 500 000
logements
rénovés dont après la moitié en dire
programme Habiter mieux c'est ce qui a
été écrit en fait dans la loi 2015 c'est
aussi dire que le curseur il doit être
là et je pense que ça permet aussi de
donner à voir de ce qu'on devrait faire
et moi j'ai aucun problème à assumer
qu'on a mis des objectifs et que ensuite
ben oui on répond et vous on a des
chiffres et ils sont pas toujours bon et
c'est évidemment un regret mais moi je
n'ai aucun regret d'avoir assumé un cap
et d'avoir dit qu'on n'était pas au
niveau au moins c'est de la transparence
et ça permet me semble-t-il aussi
travaillé mais y compris d'avoir des
vrais débats sur les questions
budgétaires parce qu'en effet avec cet
objectif là et il est moyen
d'accompagnement qui sont nécessaires on
verra que en effet on n'avait pas tous
les moyens budgétaires nécessaires mais
je reviendrai parce que c'est pas qu'une
question d'argent qui explique à mon
avis qu'on n'est pas totalement
au niveau je pense que ce que cette
audition m'a permis aussi de réfléchir
quelques années plus tard je parce qu'on
n'est pas sorti des difficultés
aujourd'hui même si je parlerai un peu
du présent et c'est vrai que je pense
qu'il y a quand même des débats qu'on a
toujours pas tranché et d'ailleurs vous
les posez dans vos questions qui doit-on
aider
est-ce qu'on est tout le monde et on
veut matifier est-ce qu'on cherche à
aider les publics des décides de revenus
les plus les plus faibles ou alors
est-ce qu'il faudrait se regarder
vraiment les plus gros émetteurs de gaz
à effet de serre pour aider eux en
premier et les forcer eux
ensuite il y a une deuxième idée qui à
mon avis continue à être fausse et je
pense que c'est une des difficultés
c'est que cette idée que la rénovation
d'un logement peut se faire à budget
constant et que finalement ça tourne
tout seul et je pense que c'est ça le du
problème moi je ne crois toujours pas
qu'il y a un modèle économique de la
rénovation ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas le faire mais propose sont très
claires je pense que c'est essentiel
qu'on progresse sur les rénovations des
logements comme des bâtiments mais le
modèle économique il est extrêmement
difficile sur le logement social il
existe pas vraiment mais c'est pas
l'enjeu d'aujourd'hui chez les
particuliers je vous dirais ça dépend un
peu de l'orage vous avez beaucoup de
public retraités propriétaires qui vous
disent aujourd'hui qu'il ne voit pas
l'intérêt de prendre de faire des
travaux extrêmement coûteux sur lesquels
ils n'auront pas de retour
d'investissement et on peut leur faire
miroiter l'idée que ils vont vendre
mieux leurs biens à terme c'est même pas
vrai partout en réalité ça dépend
beaucoup de l'attractivité du marché
immobilier ça dépend où il est situé
on voit bien là sur l'augmentation des
des passoires mises en vente qu'en fait
il y a des territoires où elles se
vendent pas moins cher donc
évidemment extrêmement attention à ça et
d'autant plus et je pense que c'est
peut-être aussi une de nos faiblesses
qui est qu'aujourd'hui des particuliers
qui investissent pour rénover leur
logement qui donc font baisser les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
leur logement donc ils investissent
peut-être qu'ils vont retrouver un
retour d'investissement évidemment sur
leur consommation d'énergie leur coût de
l'énergie et peut-être sur la vente de
leur patrimoine mais
ils n'ont jamais été en fait remerciés
entre guillemets incité par l'État pour
avoir baissé leur part des missions
carbone quand vous achetez aujourd'hui
une voiture peu émettrice vous avez une
réduction de votre carte grise vous avez
donc quand même un incitation vous
rénovez votre logement est-ce que vous
avez des incitations sur vos différentes
taxes et pourquoi je vous dis ça c'est
parce que le fait de ne pas donner de
prix au carbone et donc de ne pas donner
de prix aux économies des émissions de
carbone ça rend aussi le dossier
d'autant plus d'autant plus difficile
après
je veux je dois quand même dire que
en tout cas la preuve de ce modèle
économique n'existe pas vraiment et
peut-être que ça doit pas nous arrêter
pour faire c'est à dire que
et peut-être que c'est ça qui nous
permettrait de vraiment arriver à des
objectifs de rénovation important c'est
que justement on construise une
substitution un modèle économique qui
n'existe pas pour qu'en fait la dépense
portée par les particuliers ou même pour
les bailleurs sociaux soit en fait
acceptable et on pourrait jouer sur des
emprunts long terme sur des subventions
parce qu'évidemment il y a un coût pour
l'État de ne pas baisser ses émissions
carbone très clairement et par rapport
aux stratégies nationales bas carbone
actuel et futur et les engagements
européens mais je pense que ça explique
évidemment une des difficultés et un des
noeuds du problème parce que en tout cas
dans le cas qui est dans lequel j'étais
une de nos grosses difficultés c'était
d'avoir plus d'argent et un budget
constant sur les enjeux de la rénovation
et j'y reviendrai notamment dans le
cadre du budget de Lana parce que
c'était un enjeu particulier mais
au-delà de ça je dois aussi dire que des
choses qui n'ont d'ailleurs pas beaucoup
changé la faiblesse des partenaires
bancaires sur le sujet parce que très
clairement pour le logement social
heureusement la Caisse des dépôts est
présente et travaille toujours à des
prêts qui accompagnent au long cours et
y compris continue d'innover avec
l'ensemble des bailleurs sociaux sur le
sujet mais on n'a pas un acteur bancaire
de la rénovation comme il existe dans
d'autres pays européens qui pourraient
être un partenaire bancaire privilégié
pour des particuliers ou des
propriétaires de quelques lots je le dis
parce que c'est un des freins importants
y compris pour des ménages qui étaient
concernés par le programme habité mieux
mais qui était dans la partie la plus
haute de ces ménages fragiles et qui
avait un reste à d'emprunt
beaucoup de dossiers bloqués beaucoup de
difficultés à l'époque j'ai eu des
beaucoup discussions avec les
partenaires bancaires et je peux vous
dire pour une un résultat assez médiocre
sur leur mobilisation sur leur facilité
sur l'acceptation de financer ces
dossiers enfin dans les dans les
difficultés qui existaient à l'époque et
qui expliquent une partie de l'échec et
qui sont toujours là c'est le régime de
la copropriété
qui est très clairement pas adapté à
cette accélération des travaux à cette
massification et même si on a fait des
progrès collectifs très importants ce
régime a été changé à plusieurs reprises
on a créé le fonds travaux on a
énormément travaillé travailler sur les
sujets les plus ardues je pense
évidemment aux copropriétés dégradées la
création quand même des Horcruxes quand
même au travail considérable qui avait
été fait par le sénateur Claudine c'est
extrêmement important de se rappeler ça
parce qu'on part vraiment de très loin
avant le travail du sénateurs
Seine-Saint-Denis franchement on avait
des outils totalement pas au niveau
aujourd'hui les encodes de hyène il y en
a énormément qui ont été créés et c'est
vraiment une solution mais là on parle
des copro très très dégradés la question
c'est le reste des régimes de
copropriété et de la difficulté à faire
voter des travaux et à intéresser
l'ensemble des bailleurs pour pour les
aider alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui là
après cette année d'un tarif de
l'énergie extrêmement cher et un peu fou
vous allez me dire bah le modèle
économique on le voit très bien qu'on
est arrivé de l'énergie extrêmement
extrêmement fort mais moi si je me
rappelle les années 2015-2016 on n'est
pas du tout dans le même niveau on est
dans un tarif de l'énergie extrêmement
bas
une sorte de très grandes difficultés à
convaincre les ménages que c'est bon
pour leur pouvoir d'achat de faire des
travaux à l'avenir et et objectivement
une difficulté d'enclencher les choses
bon néanmoins beaucoup de choses ont été
faites
d'une part il y a eu quand même des
modifications législatives importantes
alors il y a l'ensemble des dispositifs
de la loi transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte je vais pas revenir
surtout puis je pense que vous aurez
vous aurez des questions mais l'idée
était quand même d'essayer alors à
l'époque c'était assorti d'un crédit
d'impôt d'une part pour les ménages qui
payaient des impôts et puis le
renforcement du programme habité mieux
qui maintenant si j'ai bien compris
s'appelle ma prime rénov sérénité mais
bon habiter mieux voilà qui était pour
les ménages les plus modestes avec
vraiment des subventions et un portage
assez maximum pour les ménages les plus
pauvres et puis des aides pour des
ménages qui vous pouvez aussi emprunter
une partie une partie de de comment dire
de des travaux je pense que la très
grande difficulté dans cette période là
c'est en fait sur comment comment est
construit les programmes de rénovation
donc on a cette cet outil formidable qui
est la nana l'agence nationale
d'amélioration de l'habitat je le dis
ici qui est un outil qui nous est envié
moi quand j'étais ministre j'étais
sollicitée à plusieurs reprises par les
ministres du logement en Allemagne et
dans d'autres pays européens mais aussi
parce qu'on avait posé la question
aquito j'ai fait beaucoup de rencontres
avec des délégations étrangères qui
voulaient tous savoir ce que c'était que
cette agence nationale et comment
était-il possible que l'État investisse
pour l'habitat c'était quand même très
intéressant et c'est comme l'enruque est
quand même un modèle intéressant mais
Lana contrairement à l'enrue n'a pas de
capacité à engager des fonds de manière
plus réelle et c'est bien le projet rien
de problème
à la rue sur les programmes de
rénovation urbaine on est sur une
programmation à 10 ans avec donc on
décaisse pas on programme des dépenses
budgétaires
qui sont assortis de maquettes
financière et dans des comités
d'engagement puis après il y a du
décaissement par dépenses Lana c'est une
agence mais le problème c'est que chaque
année son volume de dossier à gérer et à
faire entre eux alors à l'époque habité
mieux les logements qui étaient adaptés
je sais plus comment ça s'appelait mais
donc l'adaptation des logements et puis
les autres programmes c'est des volumes
de dossiers que la NAS doit ensuite
répartir au niveau territorial et en
fait ça dépend du niveau budgétaire qui
qui est fixé et c'est une des
difficultés parce qu'à plusieurs
reprises et y compris avant 2012 ça a
été tout le problème y compris sous le
quinquennat précédent 2012 Lana en
fonction des consommations bonnes ou pas
bonnes des dossiers se retrouver en
cours d'année soit arrêter de financer
les dossiers soit les bloquer et comme
c'était des dossiers en co-financement
avec les collectivités territoriales
plus avec les opérateurs associatifs qui
faisaient l'accompagnement social on
s'est retrouvé avec quand même une
construction de méfiance très forte
entre les opérateurs et la NAS sur
est-ce que vraiment comme vous me dites
vous allez faire je suis pas mille
dossiers dans telle collectivité est-ce
que vraiment vous allez me financer les
1000 dans l'année
sauf que c'est tellement long de porter
un dossier de rénovation pour un public
précaire entre l'accompagnement social
le montage des dossiers de subvention la
sollicitation des collectivités locales
des différentes aides que quand vous
apprenez huit mois plus tard que le
dossier finalement n'est pas financé
qu'on attend l'année prochaine en fait
ça s'arrête et je pense que ça reste une
très grande difficulté pour ces dossiers
là ou en fait on a on n'a pas une
capacité à dire qu'on construit quelque
chose de plus réelle donc ça veut dire
aussi qu'on change la manière de
construire le budget de Lana et le débat
budgétaire autour et qui permettrait
certainement de pas connaître les
à-coups et notamment vous m'interrogez
là dans les questions que vous m'avez
soumises sur ma mon choix de changer les
objectifs de la NA en mars 2016
très clairement en mars 2016 Lana devait
faire 50000 logements dans le programme
habité mieux donc les publics modestes
je dis à Lana vous allez en faire 70 000
et on met les moyens financiers qui vont
avec
et je à l'époque on est beaucoup à
penser qu'en fait il y a plus
d'impulsions et plus de budget ça suffit
à faire en réalité à la fin de l'année
ils feront 41000 dossiers donc même pas
les 50 000 prévus et donc une incapacité
totale à
le faire et je vous cache pas que j'ai
été vraiment j'ai considéré ça comme un
échec patant pour moi pour les services
de l'État pour l'ensemble des ministères
et on a essayé de comprendre pourquoi en
réalité quand on décide en mars 2016 de
passer à 70 000 Lana repose donc certes
une agence mail repose sur des services
qui sont soit déconcentrés soit des
centralisée avec une délégation
collectivité
les objectifs de 70 000 donc qui
augmentent les niveaux doivent être
redescendus dans les comités régionaux
de l'habitat de l'hébergement et de
votée c'est comme sur les aides à la
pierre puis après faut interroger les
collectivités pour savoir si elles vont
accompagner en co-financement les
projets supplémentaires et en réalité on
se rendra compte que pour beaucoup et
compréhension une fois qu'on a fait le
premier ratio qui était prévu on va pas
plus loin et donc une incapacité à
travailler en flux à travailler au long
cours à commencer à engager des dossiers
et à les accompagner c'est aussi une
année ça l'a expliqué il y a plusieurs
collectivités y compris importante au
niveau régional qui avait changé de
positionnement sur leur accompagnement
des dossiers de la NAS qui a quand même
été très préjudiciable pour les pour les
ménages et aussi très clairement et ça
avait été montré que
l'accompagnement financier n'était pas
suffisant en fait il y avait un reste à
charge trop important même dans les
programmes habité mieux qui étaient en
blocage très clairement pour les ménages
pour lancer les programmes
et que et donc il prenait pas le risque
mais c'est vrai que on est en 2023 le
budget de la nana n'est pas non plus
plus réelle et je m'interroge toujours à
posteriori si on a réussi à le faire sur
la rue alors sur des sommes qui n'ont
rien à voir certes je regrette qu'on
puisse pas le faire sur la nappe l'autre
difficulté de la NAS de l'époque vous le
savez c'est que son budget était
construit avec la question des quotas
carbone donc moi j'ai pas eu de chance
je suis la période où en fait ils se
sont effondrés et je vous cache pas
comment garder tous les mois qu'elle
était le niveau d'écoute à carbone ce
qui fait qu'en fait plusieurs fois la
directrice de Lana m'appelait en me
disant je ne sais pas si combien de
dossiers je peux engager parce que ça va
des variations et qui objectivement leur
budget n'était pas pérennisé et je pense
que c'était
une des une des difficultés alors on y a
appris aussi de ça en 2017 d'une part on
a envoyé les programmations beaucoup
plus tôt à l'ensemble des des régions et
des préfets de région en février 2017 et
puis on a essayé de baisser la part du
quota carbone dans le budget de Lana
vous l'auriez compris en fonctionnant 50
millions à Action Logement je le dis ici
mais c'était aussi un moyen de trouver
une plus grande stabilité pour
l'accompagnement de ces ménages mais ça
explique en tout cas sur les sur ces
dossiers habités mieux qui était une
priorité pour tous de la difficulté à y
aller
l'autre chose après je m'arrêterai parce
que je suis un peu trop longue
au cours des années 2014-2015 2016 donc
y compris avec au moment de la
discussion de la loi pour la transition
énergétique et la croissance verte on
est aussi je vais le dire franchement le
secteur du bâtiment est pas totalement
prêt à la massification de la rénovation
on rénove en France j'ai retrouvé pour
travailler cette audition une étude du
sdes de 2012 ou 2013 qui montre les
volumes de rénovation dans la période
précédente ça existe mais là on parle de
massifié et donc pour massifier il faut
s'appuyer sur l'ensemble des artisans
notamment on a beaucoup travaillé à
l'époque avec la cape parce que c'est un
des sujets on a un type de d'entreprise
dans l'artisanat du bâtiment qui est des
petites entreprises avec des enjeux de
formation qui sont pas évidentes parce
que quand vous êtes que deux ou trois
dans chaque entreprise vous vous formez
pas aussi facilement que ça et donc à la
question du geste et c'est pour ça qu'en
fait en 2014 avec Sylvia Pinel et j'ai
ensuite moi mis en place la suite on a
travaillé sur trois axes il y avait le
BIM c'est-à-dire
enfin que l'ensemble des professionnels
du bâtiment s'adaptent à la question
numérique digitale et à la maîtrise du
BIM
vous avez bien vu qu'on n'y est pas
encore y compris la question du carnet
numérique du logement je crois vient
juste là de sortir alors que c'est dans
la loi 2015 il y avait la question de la
règle de l'art parce que le débat sur le
type de travaux la capacité à faire
est-ce que on pousse correctement les
isolants les fenêtres et tout ça était
un sujet d'où le débat derrière sur la
question de RGE et donc la question de
la garantie pour avoir les projets
financés qui étaient qui étaient un
projet extrêmement important et c'est
vrai que ce que nous on a cherché à
l'époque c'est de d'essayer de créer un
écosystème qui pousse en fait l'ensemble
des opérateurs à être mieux formés et
accompagner cette massification
et je pense que c'est évidemment
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui un enjeu assez
important en fait pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir avancer
voilà donc vous l'aurez compris toute
façon quand on est ministre du Logement
je vais vous dire si on pense qu'on a un
bon bilan c'est qu'on a pas tout compris
parce que si jamais fini non mais faut
être extrêmement humble en fait
moi je pense qu'on a fait des choses
extrêmement intéressantes et qu'on a
posé les jalons en fait de ce qui a
permis la suite et je parlerai si vous
le souhaitez évidemment des décisions
qui ont été prises par la suite mais oui
ça allait pas ça va pas ça n'allait pas
assez vite et ça ne va pas assez vite
aujourd'hui et et c'est en plus dans un
moment où en fait depuis 10 ans le
marché immobilier n'a jamais été aussi
florissant je pense que c'est ça aussi
qui est extrêmement compliqué c'est que
même si là il y a un petit coup d'arrêt
avec la loi climère résilience jusqu'à
jusqu'à cette année en fait n'importe
quel logement s'il est bien situé se
vend à des prix complètement dingues
quel que soit sa qualité énergétique ce
qui est fou ce qui est fou et ce qui
explique un problème et à côté de ça on
est encore face à des fléaux l'habitat
insalubre et indigne qui demeure très
important dans notre pays qu'on n'a pas
éradiquer
et là notre sujet n'est pas juste la
question de du DPE et de la classe
énergétique c'est vraiment autre chose
donc je pense que c'est c'est aussi pour
ça que
même si beaucoup de choses ont été
faites et j'espère seront poursuivis
objectivement en direct c'est un bilan
un bilan mitigé même si moi j'assume
totalement en fait
qu'on évolue avoir des objectifs pour
dire qu'en fait c'était le minimum qu'il
fallait faire
coucou madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur c'est à vous
merci madame la Présidente merci madame
la ministre pour cette exposé
non peut-être rebondir sur ce que vous
venez de dire sur justement ce que vous
avez fait un balayage de
forcément de votre période avec la loi
de la loi de 2015 et puis son son
application
mais peut-être si vous pouvez revenir
sur votre vision justement de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui parce que c'est vrai
que quelque part vous avez fait un petit
peu essuyé les plates en tout cas mis
des choses en place des objectifs c'est
vrai que c'était quasi les premiers
objectifs d'atteindre ces 500 000 1500
000 logements vous avez expliqué
effectivement la nécessité à la fois des
objectifs mais quand même le constat qui
qu'ils ont pas été complètement
complètement atteints et peut-être votre
vision sur ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
où on remet des objectifs et qu'on ne
les atteint pas encore une fois
en tout cas peut-être et puis sur les
modifications des dispositifs qu'on peut
être mis en place et peut-être avec ce
risque un petit peu d'empilement et de
manque de lisibilité en tout cas
j'aimerais bien avoir votre votre avis
sur sur
peut-être sur les différents éléments
qui ont été mis en place justement à
partir de 2015 on a eu Ségolène Royal
donc on a pu aussi lui poser les
questions mais sur je crois qu'il y
avait quelque chose d'intéressant sur la
réflexion des plateformes territoriales
de rénovation thermique et justement
avec
cette appui local à la fois approximité
et travailler avec les collectivités
locales à travers notamment été
post-type etc et sur lequel je trouve on
avait mis en place un certain maillage
et qui peut être aujourd'hui justement
manque un peu d'appui en tout cas de de
soutien donc aussi avoir peut-être votre
votre avis votre avis là-dessus
également peut-être parce que je crois
que vous en aviez parlé en tout cas vous
aviez travaillé sur cette question sur
un service public de l'efficacité
énergétique et pareil d'avoir un ce cet
échelle là en tout cas ce mécanisme qui
permette on a parlé juste avant aussi
avec Cécile Duflot sur le entre les
politiques locales qui peuvent se mettre
qui peuvent se mettre en place et puis
la nécessité d'avoir une coordination
nationale quoi et donc peut-être d'avoir
cette échelle justement avec ce service
public et puis pour laisser de la place
à mes autres collègues sur peut-être sur
la question du RGE vous avez parlé
justement de la question de l'importance
des entreprises de la formation de
l'accompagnement et notamment aussi sur
des nouvelles techniques
et c'est vrai que sur cette mise en
place du RGE ce label qui est mis en
place avoir votre avis justement après
coup je dirais sur sur comment comment
vous voyez les choses et notamment
peut-être au regard de ce qui peut pas
qui peut se passer sur d'autres d'autres
pays où en fait on est moins sur une
qualification des entreprises mais
plutôt sur la qualité des travaux
réalisés sur place
donc avoir peut-être votre votre avis
sur cette mise en place de du RGE
vis-à-vis des entreprises voilà merci
monsieur le rapporteur alors sur ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui et je dirais sur ce
qui s'est passé après 2017
enfin ce que je trouve assez compliqué
même s'il est dispositifs qui avaient
été mis en place mérité évidemment
d'être complété ajuster tout ça c'est en
fait que moi j'ai eu l'impression quand
même que on réinventé toujours quelque
chose
typiquement vous parlez des plateformes
territoriales après ils ont créé si je
dis pas de bêtises ce qu'ils ont appelé
je sais pas comment la star enfin en
fait on peut quand même se demander
peut-être une maladie des politiques que
nous sommes que nous avons été mais
est-ce que vraiment il faut à chaque
fois renommer tous les deux ans
notamment sur un domaine aussi compliqué
parce que déjà la création des
plateformes territoriales c'était un peu
pour essayer de reprendre justement de
faire une sorte de partenariat parce que
parler des collectivités mais c'était
bien ça le sujet dans la loi sur la
transition énergétique et pas que sur la
question du bâtiment il y a quand même
beaucoup de de sujets qui sont en lien
avec une une association des
collectivités terriales sur l'ensemble
des politiques énergétiques il y a
beaucoup de choses le contexte de loi
qui sont là dessus et c'est notamment le
cas sur la rénovation et y compris et
notamment en raison de l'accompagnement
social qui peut être amené mais aussi de
la difficulté de trouver le bon de vie
la bonne entreprise le bon
accompagnement en tout cas nous on n'a
jamais pensé que on allait faire la
rénovation énergétique par le haut sans
s'appuyer sur les politiques locales de
l'énergie d'ailleurs si c'est plutôt un
peu un parti free différent c'est qu'on
essayait de susciter par le biais de ces
dispositifs là de créer des politiques
de l'énergie et don de la rénovation à
une échelle plus locale alors notamment
à l'échelle de l'agglomération mais pas
que parce qu'il y a des endroits les
départements étaient très engagés il y a
des endroits il y avait la région qui
étaient en partenariat avec Lana mais
quand même il faut le dire partout où
des agglos ont dans les années 2010
créer un une maison de l'habitat un
service public qu'elles ont pu appeler
local de l'énergie ça où il y avait un
accompagnement sur le territoire on a eu
plus de dossiers faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont si vous demandez à
Lana les les remontées de dossier par
agglo et que vous comparez par rapport à
la présence en fait d'un accompagnement
local vous verrez que c'est toujours
différent et donc c'est vrai que
et ça allait avec par ailleurs les
territoires énergies positifs les
démonstrateurs de la ville durable enfin
il y avait une volonté très clairement
d'être beaucoup appuyée enfin appuyer
c'est peut-être pas le terme je dirais
plutôt qu'il y ait une collaboration en
partenariat sur la politique c'est à
dire que l'État fixe des objectifs y
compris des questions de qualité
d'exigence et tout ça mais ça s'appuie
sur un partenariat avec les
collectivités locales et sincèrement je
ne suis pas sûr ce qui a été décidé
après était finalement très utile de
tout défaire d'ailleurs je le dis
franchement peut-être aussi pour
contrôler plus l'action des
collectivités locales alors qu'à mon
avis sur ce sujet là une
décentralisation fine peut-être
extrêmement intéressante et
si vous voulez je pense que ça va
au-delà de la question de la compétence
je pense qu'il est des niveau les agglos
par rapport au bassin de vie qu'elle
qu'elle en robe sont les plus
compétentes il y a des territoires
ruraux c'est peut-être plus intéressant
que ça soit le département ça dépend
aussi de la qualité des services de
proximité qui peuvent qui peuvent
exister mais justement je pense qu'on
avait ouvert un peu un certain nombre de
sujets et ça quand même pas été simple
parce que c'est plateformes il fallait
les mettre en oeuvre il fallait les
définir y compris alors le service
public de l'efficacité énergétique on
s'est beaucoup posé de questions sur
comment le définir parce que le texte de
loi tel qu'il est issu du travail
parlementaire était pas si simple que ça
mais il y avait quand même l'idée
d'apporter à l'ensemble des ménages un
minimum de services et de satisfaction
et ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
quoi c'est donc d'une part une volonté
de un peu en fait faire en sorte en gros
de dire aussi que ce qui était fait
avant était pas bien mais on sait pas
trop ce qui a été proposé après elle
était mieux et puis il y a le tournant
de la loi climat et résilience alors moi
que je trouve je vous le dis franchement
très intéressant et je pense que le
problème est pas tant ce que dit la loi
dans ses objectifs et y compris cette
évolution avec son sujet des obligations
très fortes que les moyens qui sont liés
et notamment de la déclinaison je le dis
franchement
et moi en tant que ministre j'étais pas
favorable en 2016 à l'interdiction de
location de logement pour les classes
les plus énergivores notamment pour une
raison assez simple et je sais que
d'autres mini du logement avaient même
avec moi c'est que les DPE de l'époque
étaient absolument pas fiables
absolument pas fiable et on pourra
débattre avec vous si vous souhaitez de
la fiabilité des DPE actuellement en
tout cas les DPE de l'époque ne sont pas
fiables et par ailleurs ma grande
crainte et je ne suis pas la seule à
l'avoir c'était que si on avait des
objectifs d'interdiction trop rapprochés
trop dur on remettait du logement dans
le marché noir comme ça existait dans
les trucs de la main à la main et
notamment chez les précaires
énergétiques et et c'est là en fait le
véritable sujet et d'ailleurs parce que
c'est un débat qui est ancien qui a eu
lieu dans la loi de 2015 qui avait eu un
peu lieu dans la loi alur
qui a été discuté à l'époque mais
objectivement on n'avait pas la capacité
et y compris le DPE de l'époque était
pas du tout fiable pour le faire après
il y a la loi climat résilience qui d'un
seul coup dit ça va être comme ça
je note tout de même que à l'époque
l'étude d'impact pour savoir de combien
de logement on parle y compris sur la
partie sociale et extrêmement
défaillante
après bon on est on est cinq ans plus
tard
moi je me dis bon bah si c'est
maintenant le choix de législateur
allons-y pourquoi pas néanmoins la
difficulté c'est quoi c'est que le
fiasco de la mise en place du nouveau
DPE sincèrement
pour des tas de raisons c'est qu'en fait
c'est un outil extrêmement complexe que
enfin bon j'ai assisté à tellement de
réunions alors là en tant que présidente
de l'Union HLM pour
essayer d'avoir des outils fiables et
c'est extrêmement compliqué ça l'est
toujours je vous le savez quand encore
aujourd'hui on n'a pas l'ensemble des
des facilités sur les DPE notamment à
l'immeuble on est début 2023 imaginez si
des gens découvrent en cours d'année
qu'ils ont un logement qui est classé
j'ai ça leur laisse un an et demi pour
se faire les travaux c'est extrêmement
rapide mais
néanmoins à partir du moment le
législateur dit on va faire cette cette
interdiction pour des tas de bonnes
raisons et moi je les conteste pas parce
qu'objectivement un logement et pas et
en effet énergivores et pas le plus
confortable et y compris ça peut poser
des vraies questions néanmoins on dit
que c'est un logement indécent donc ça
pose des questions et la grande crainte
c'est ce qui se passe le 1er janvier
2025 moi je vous cache pas que c'est
évidemment mon souci actuel et de ce
point de vue là ce que je regrette c'est
pas tant qu'on ait mis ses objectifs
très durs qui ont quand même créé une
vraie dynamique de réhabilitation dans
l'ensemble du pays mais que les colonies
d'accompagnement soit pas au niveau de
cette révolution si on peut parler ainsi
parce qu'on parle quand même de
plusieurs millions de logements qu'il
faut sortir de l'indécence d'ici deux
ans dans le temps du logement c'est
extrêmement court et et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que sur ces politiques pour
qu'elle soit efficace bien plus que sur
d'autres domaines très clairement on a
besoin de stabilité de pérennité et de
durée
mais bon ça c'est voilà si on se met au
rythme du logement on voit bien qu'il
faut il faut du temps c'est il faut du
temps pour construire les deux vitres
trouver l'entreprise faire les travaux
et je pense que c'est ça c'est ça pour
moi la très grande difficulté enfin sur
votre dernière question sur RGE qualité
des travaux plutôt que de la qualité de
la formation de l'entreprise
objectivement je j'ai jamais réfléchi
comme ça donc je sais pas pas vous
répondre ce qui est quand même certains
c'est qu'on a besoin de former les
entreprises parce que RGE n'est pas
arrivé par hasard il est aussi arrivé
parce qu'on avait des difficultés sur
certains chantiers qu'on avait et on en
a toujours et moi je pense qu'il faut
pas simplement être dans le coercitif et
dans le contrôle il faut justement
trouver à former mieux nos artisans à
leur trouver les moyens de pouvoir se
former on a beaucoup de parler d'avoir
des plateformes plus locales justement
où les artisans pourraient mutualiser y
compris pour répondre à certains appels
d'offres etc et pour justement améliorer
le geste
c'est quand même un métier manuel je
reviens à ça et voilà isoler des
logements c'est pas ça se fait pas comme
ça et en plus il y a la question
aujourd'hui des maîtrises de matériaux
et tout ça qui est extrêmement
importantes donc je sais qu'aujourd'hui
la question
la certification RGE est en question
qu'il y a moins d'entreprises qui sont
certifiées aujourd'hui qu'hier après on
peut peut-être interroger les
fédérations
du secteur pour savoir pourquoi elle
pousse pas leurs entreprises à ne pas se
certifier mais moi je pense quand même
que la question de la qualification dans
le métier du bâtiment elle est
essentielle et d'ailleurs vous le savez
très bien les assurances endommage
ouvrage ont beaucoup augmenté notamment
parce qu'on a beaucoup plus de malfaçons
par le passé donc et il a il s'agit pas
de jeter la pierre à un secteur
économique il s'agit plutôt se demander
comme on l'accompagne comme on le forme
et y compris la massification des
métiers de la rénovation ça veut dire
aussi qu'on forme différemment parce que
derrière la question il y a aussi une
question alors là vraiment du geste qui
est que
chaque maison chaque logement chaque
bâti évidemment différent mais aussi si
on doit apprendre qu'en fonction du type
de bâtiment des matériaux des années on
va avoir des rénovations qui vont être
un peu standardisées et ça aussi ça se
travaille mais donc ça veut dire aussi
que l'on est capable d'apporter des
outils de formation moderne où les gens
sont pas obligés de se déplacer qui
peuvent peut-être le faire à distance ou
pour justement apprendre à faire cette
évolution là et donc à répondre à la
question de la massification ça va pas
être parce que
il y a ça aussi c'est que d'autres pays
arrivent mieux que nous parce qu'ils ont
un bâtiment peut-être moins interrogène
plus récent mais aussi qu'ils ont
massifié leur standard de rénovation et
je vous dis pas qu'il faut qu'on fasse
tout pareil je dis simplement qu'il faut
qu'on apprenne quand on traite certains
bâtiments des années 50 qui sont
toujours les mêmes ou de la maison
individuelle des années 80 on a des
gestes qu'on peut répéter qui me semble
assez assez essentiel
merci alors il y avait une question de
Philippe Folliot
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues tout
d'abord je vous prie de m'excuser parce
que j'ai pas pu assister à toutes les
toutes les auditions et madame la
ministre je vais vous poser une question
que j'aurais pu tout aussi bien me poser
à vos prédécesseurs ou à vos successeurs
mais finalement elle aura d'autant plus
d'intérêt que peut-être contrairement à
certaines d'entre eux qui ne sont plus
dans la sphère du logement si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi vous vous y êtes encore
ne serait-ce titre de fonctions
actuelles de présidente de l'USH
vous nous avez parlé de de l'habitat
précaire et indigne
cet habitat je voudrais concerne tout le
territoire national mais peut-être plus
particulièrement nos outre-mer
et il y a un enjeu qui est un enjeu
peut-être un peu un peu spécifique par
rapport à ça si ma mémoire ne me fait
pas défaut
je crois que Lana dont vous avez parlé
intervient à hauteur de 0,20 % dans les
outre-mer alors c'est vrai que pour les
enjeux strictement et strictoensus de
rénovation énergétique tout au moins par
rapport à la partie chauffage puisque
bon après il y a d'autres éléments qui
entrent en ligne de compte mise à part
peut-être Saint-Pierre Miquelon et et
certaines parties analtitude je pense à
la Réunion au cœur de Lille et peut-être
un altitude dans les Antilles il y a
peut-être moins d'impact sur sur cet
enjeu chauffage à proprement parler mais
voilà je pense que cet élément de
spécificité n'est peut-être pas toujours
assez prise en compte et ce que vous
pouvez nous dire finalement ce que vous
et qu'est-ce que vous avez pu faire en
qualité de ministre en la matière ce que
vos successeurs auraient pu faire et
n'ont-ils pas fait pour prendre en
compte cette spécificité de nos
territoires
ultramarins et est-ce que selon vous une
des options de ce repas que finalement
les organisations
j'allais dire professionnelle
ultramarine y compris au sein de l'USH
ou des élus
ultramarins puissent faire partie
des structures ou être associées aux
structure de gouvernance nationale je
pense à l'ANA là c'est GLS à la rue et à
d'autres structures qui qui à un moment
donné peuvent peut-être essayer
d'apporter un focus sur ce cadre là vous
avez compris qu'en plus c'est un élu qui
est un élu d'un département ni pas ultra
marin qui vous le dit
mais voilà je je pense que c'est des
points et des questions qui passent
souvent si vous permettez l'expression
un peu sous les radars et pour
lesquelles je crois qu'il y a peut-être
aussi quelques quelques éléments
d'intérêt d'attention que nous pouvons
avoir
alors tout d'abord monsieur le sénateur
c'est vrai que je pense voilà on est sur
les efficacité des politiques de
rénovation des logements mais la
question de l'éradication de l'habitat
insalubre et intime reste une question
entière pour l'ensemble des territoires
de métropole et d'outre-mer avec en
effet de toute façon dans les outre-mer
dans certains endroits à la présence
encore de bidonville en masse
mais je n'enlève pas le sujet y compris
en France métropolitaine que ça soit en
zone très tendue où on a du bâti
faubourguin dans pas mal de métropoles
et dans l'habitat rurale où on a un
enjeu énorme et je vous cache pas je
pense que une vraie politique du
logement de de grosses ambitions
aujourd'hui ça serait vraiment de mettre
l'argent sur l'éradication de ce de cet
habitat qui va bien au-delà des enjeux
de la rénovation et des et des coûts de
la rénovation après sur l'autre mer et
ça pose la question c'est qu'en fait
vous le savez que sur les enjeux de
logement on a énormément de retard sur
l'ensemble des sujets et donc c'est vrai
que que Lana intervient aujourd'hui peu
parce qu'en fait l'habitat privé enfin
il y a de l'habitat privé vétuste et à
rénover mais c'est vrai qu'on a en plus
il y a beaucoup de difficultés sur la
difficulté à retrouver dans certains
territoires les titres de propriété à
aider les ménages mais aussi on va dire
les choses je pense que si l'ANA va un
budget plus important certainement qui
aurait plus de moyens qui sont allés il
y a des territoires ruraux il y a
beaucoup d'habitats à rénover ou Lana
met très peu en fait d'argent
aujourd'hui donc je pense que c'est une
difficulté c'est aussi une difficulté
par le fait et c'est pour ça que je
reviens à la question de la question de
décentralisation il y a des départements
en outre-mer où les collectivités sont
très avancées sur ce sujet là ou
justement parce qu'elles sont très
présentes et qu'elles ont déployées des
actions on peut avoir des partenariats
avec Lana qui soit assez efficace alors
que dans d'autres territoires en fait il
y a pas encore cette politique après il
y a une question quand même qui se pose
et vous le savez c'est que la politique
du logement de l'outre-mer elle est pas
portée par le ministre du Logement mais
elle est portée par le ministre de
l'Outre-mer qui a un choix depuis
plusieurs années y compris avec cette
ligne budgétaire qui s'appelle la LBU
alors ça veut pas dire que le ministère
du Logement n'y est pas il y a une sorte
de cotutelle mais c'est quand même le
ministère de l'autre mère qui le porte
beaucoup plus ce qui explique aussi que
dans certaines négociations
je pense que
peut-être par je sais pas si c'est une
habitude mais en fait y compris on met
moins l'accent de fait dans dans ces
sujets là après sur l'enrue on a
évidemment des sujets des sujets traités
en outre-mer avec beaucoup de programmes
beaucoup de programmes en cours mais en
tout cas ça explique peut-être aussi que
on n'est pas mis assez l'accent sur
l'intervention dans ces départements et
d'ailleurs madame la Présidente ça me
fait penser à une question que monia est
posée j'ai pas répondu sur est-ce que
être ministre de plein exercice ça aide
alors la réponse elle est oui
non mais il y a pas de débat à voir là
dessus oui pourquoi parce que vous êtes
en plein exercice vous êtes au Conseil
des ministres toutes les semaines et
c'est ce que j'ai eu hier sur sa voir si
le fait que on soit cette politique soit
portée par deux ministères étaient un
problème moi j'étais en coat tutelle
avec le ministère de la transition
écologique avec Ségolène Royal
l'ensemble de nos de nos on était en CO
tutelle parfaite sur tous ces sujets là
mais comme on était deux ministres de
plein exercice je peux vous dire quoi
enfin on a beaucoup travaillé ensemble
on a fait les arbitrages ensemble enfin
en tout cas il n'y avait jamais de
difficulté de ce point de vue là et ça
change tout évidemment que ça change
tout alors après on pourrait se poser la
question est-ce qu'il faudrait que ces
politiques soient portées par un seul
ministère sincèrement je ne sais pas
pourquoi je dis je ne sais pas parce que
ça dépend de quel côté vous vous
regardez est-ce qu'on regarde cette
politique uniquement par rapport aux
émissions carbone qu'elle fait éviter au
pays
ou est-ce qu'on les regarde par rapport
à la condition d'habitabilité et de la
Condition d'habitat des personnes et je
dis je pense que les deux regards sont
légitimes et sont importants et c'est ce
qui a peut amener y compris parfois à
des désaccords entre les ministères mais
mais je ne suis pas sûr que ça a été un
frein je pense qu'en tout cas à l'époque
nos freins étaient plutôt sur le fait
que au manquait d'outils ont manqué
certainement d'un budget pérenne de
plurauité et puis aussi de compréhension
parce que on ne s'était pas le sujet le
plus prioritaire de l'époque mais voilà
pour répondre à votre question
rapidement sur le sujet
madame la ministre j'aimerais revenir
sur un sujet bien évoqué d'ailleurs mais
sur lequel j'ai l'impression que vous
avez une position assez claire et qui je
pense nous intéressent et cette notion
de décentralisation finale qu'est-ce que
vous entendez par des centralisation
quelle forme cela pourrait prendre
est-ce que ça pourrait prendre la forme
d'une contractualisation d'une
décentralisation complète on sait
aujourd'hui on a pas mal de PCI qui
demandent d'ailleurs cette compétence
qui paierait
donc quelle forme ça pourrait prendre
est-ce que ce serait un guichet est-ce
que ce serait une pluriannuelle voilà
quel est votre vision des choses avec
l'expérience que vous avez merci alors
tout d'abord sur la décentralisation et
des compétences qu'on peut décentraliser
moi je pense qu'il faut toujours qu'on
se pose la question pourquoi on le fait
est-ce qu'on le fait au nom d'une
meilleure efficacité
et en pensant que les collectivités
locales qui vont être compétentes seront
plus efficaces pour répondre aux enjeux
ou est-ce qu'on se fait pour se
débarrasser d'un fardeau ou d'un échec
je le dis devant vous parce que un jour
on va se revoir pour parler de la
décentralisation des compétences du
logement qui est paraît-il le débat à
venir et je le pose vraiment comme ça
parce que moi c'est un point de vue très
personnel moi je suis plutôt depuis
longtemps convaincu de la
décentralisation sur ces sujets là
encore faut-il qu'on assure la
régulation la défense de l'intérêt
général et la question que vous l'avez
dit tout de suite des ressources parce
que si les collectivités quelle que soit
la politique se retrouvent en compétence
mais n'ont pas de ressources financières
qu'elles soient fiscale ou autre pour
assurer leur
cette nouvelle compétence elles feront
certes beaucoup mais à un moment elle
n'y arriveront pas et donc c'est vrai
que typiquement sur ces enjeux de
rénovation où y compris aujourd'hui on a
un budget beaucoup plus important
y compris un enjeu national parce que on
est engagé dans la stratégie nationale
bas carbone et y compris sur des
engagements européens donc y compris
l'État ne peut pas s'exonérer en fait
d'être parti prenante de la de la
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre moi il me semble intéressant
que cette politique qui soit débattue et
conçue au niveau national puisse
s'appuyer sur les collectivités alors
soit dans une décentralisation fine qui
en effet pourrait prendre la forme d'un
partenariat mais partenariats exigeants
qui permet en fait de poser des
objectifs locaux en connaissance de
l'état local du bâti d'objectif Fleury
annuels et d'une garantie des
financements sur la partie plus réelle
parce que c'est bien ça le sujet
et notamment parce que ça coûte cher de
rénover on en a très peu parlé de des
coûts de la rénovation on parle pas de
petites opération à 5000 euros au
logement c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui pour sortir un
logement G on va dire de la critique
c'est-à-dire de le ramener au moins en
dés on est à minima sur des travaux
autour de 25 à 40 000 euros et pour
beaucoup autour de 60 à 80 000 euros
donc voilà
d'ailleurs il y a beaucoup d'études sur
le sujet puis ça a augmenté depuis deux
ans donc très clairement moi j'imagine
parce que ce qui est intéressant c'est
que la collectivité qui connaît mieux en
fait son secteur de l'habitat et aussi
capable de faire du repérage je pense
que c'est une des questions il y a
certes tous les ménages qui vont savoir
utiliser les dispositifs qui vont aller
sur les plateformes et puis il y a tous
les autres et donc c'est pour ça que je
pense que c'est intéressant mais si
c'est pour plomber très vite les
collectivités par manque de garantie de
leur capacité à faire et donc on va se
le dire franchement aujourd'hui c'est
extrêmement compliqué d'avoir cette
confiance entre dans une politique
décentralisée sur les moyens de l'État
et il me semble que c'est assez
difficile néanmoins moi je crois
beaucoup que
enfin parce que je l'ai vu en fait dans
beaucoup de territoires j'ai vu y
compris des maisons de l'habitat ou les
ménagères ils sont accompagnés dans la
même structure il rencontre les
représentent par des représentants qui
expliquent les aides de la NA un
architecte qui explique les qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire ils sont informés sur
les devis ils sont informés sur les
arnaques enfin voilà enfin je pense que
vous en avez peut-être visité et je
pense que c'est très utile et en plus ça
permet par ailleurs de répondre à des
enjeux locaux enfin on a voilà donc
compris sur l'emploi local et tout ça
donc moi je pense que ça pourrait être
intéressant encore faut-il que l'on
souhaite travailler que les
collectivités locales
y a-t-il d'autres questions
non monsieur rapporteur Michel Dagbert
merci oui moi je suis très intéressé par
la décentralisation également mais avec
le point de vigilance que vous avez
relevé Madame le Ministre à savoir que
il faut à la fois de la responsabilité
et des moyens
mais ça m'a ça m'a paraît être la bonne
échelle pour une contractualisation
c'est à dire que sur la base d'un portée
à connaissance on soit capable de se
fixer des objectifs y compris de manière
plus réelle et d'affecter les enveloppes
qui vont bien pour être capables de
faire et je pense que à cette échelle là
à l'échelle de l'EPCI notamment on est
certainement en capacité de nouer un
dialogue très
très intéressant y compris avec les
acteurs du monde de l'entreprise de
l'entrepreneuriat et notamment des
artisans
j'ai eu le plaisir aussi de
connaître un dossier que vous avez
traité et à la fois en tant que
signataire
au nom et pour le compte du département
sur un enjeu assez fort dans mon
territoire qui qui est concerne
d'ailleurs deux départements celui d'une
heure et du Pas-de-Calais sur
l'engagement pour le renouveau du
bassinier on voudrait la vous remercier
pour
les délais dans lesquels toute cette
négociation s'est opérée mais aussi le
fait que à la fois dans la
responsabilité qui était la vôtre mais
aussi avec l'ensemble des partenaires
que sont la région les deux départements
et l'ensemble des EPCI nous ayons pu
arriver à une signature de cet
engagement il n'en demeure pas moins que
une difficulté se pose et à travers
celle-là je pense qu'on la retrouve dans
beaucoup de situations c'est à dire que
sur le bâti très ancien les techniques
d'isolation aujourd'hui
diminue fortement la surface habitable
et tout un chacun qui aujourd'hui veut
entrer dans ses logements
veut meubler cette habitation avec
l'ameublement de notre époque et pas
l'ameublement de l'époque à laquelle les
logements ont été construits et par
conséquent là c'est une vraie difficulté
aujourd'hui avec vous l'avez dit vous
l'avez mentionné ces derniers ces
dernières années notamment une envolée
des coûts dématériaux qui vient
renchérir énormément le coût de ces
rénovations donc c'était juste cette
remarque et avoir votre sentiment
là-dessus
alors
déjà je pense que une des difficultés
sur la rénovation c'est y compris
c'est-à-dire tout le débat aujourd'hui
sur ma prime rénove est-ce qu'on fait
quelques gestes on va par gestes c'est
ce qu'on fait complet
moi je vais vous dire franchement je
pense qu'on fait en fait en fonction de
chaque situation
parce qu'il y a des moments où en fait
économiquement vous allez pas faire une
rénovation complète parce que c'est trop
cher mais à côté de ça en effet se dire
que on rénove et qu'on fait un seul
geste donc on a ouvert un chantier on a
fait venir un artisan on a fait un devis
il fait un seul geste de rénovation
franchement on se dit c'est beaucoup en
fait de temps perdu parce qu'une fois
que le chantier est installé ça serait
mieux d'en faire au moins deux ou trois
et je pense que s'il y a vraiment un
programme à faire sur ma prime rénov
c'est au moins qu'on ait un parcours de
geste je sais pas comment l'appeler je
sais pas si ça s'appelle comme ça mais
qu'en gros à minima on puisse aider à
Seiller deux ou trois gestes parce que
un artisan en plus il va pas se déplacer
sur un volume de travaux qui est pas qui
va pas être suffisant mais encore
faut-il que les ménages puissent payer
et dans l'habitat privé tout n'est pas
n'a pas de valeur il y a des endroits où
le marché immobilier n'existe pas ou est
très faible les biens n'ont pas beaucoup
de valeur et des ménages qui même
propriétaire ont pas des capacités
financières énormes et ça je pense quand
même que c'est un problème alors c'est
vraiment un problème dans le cadre de la
rénovation des particuliers parce qu'en
l'ensemble des gros propriétaires
bailleurs qu'ils soient sociaux ou
privés eux vont travailler très
différemment on va être toujours sur
deux ou trois classes de gagner même si
on est aussi confronté à la rénovation
des maisons individuelles et donc
confrontées à ce que vous venez de dire
monsieur le sénateur sur notamment ses
bâti individuelles classées alors il y a
évidemment le patrimoine du bassin
minier du Pas-de-Calais et du Nord il y
a l'ensemble des cités jardin mais c'est
beaucoup de logements si tes jardins et
puis encore un peu d'habitat dans la
sidérurgie dans le Grand Est avec en
effet ces questions là qui sont des
habitats qui sont d'une part qui était
pas très grandes déjà en surface avant
et se pose la question typiquement
rajouter des cuisines rajouter des vrais
salles de bains rajouter des vrais
toilettes
avec aussi je le redis une priorité
sortir du fioul et du charbon parce que
quand même c'était ça aussi qui était
qui était nécessaire et alors vous
l'avez dit c'est aussi des bâti qui ne
supportent pas tout type de technique de
rénovation alors l'avantage de cette
contractualisation sur l'engagement pour
le renouveau du bassin minier en 2017
qui était un projet en effet on s'est
beaucoup battu collectivement et je
pense que si aussi cet engagement a
perduré existe encore aujourd'hui c'est
aussi parce qu'on l'a construit avec les
collectivités on a quand même fait avant
ministère beaucoup de réunions avec
l'ensemble des agglomérations concernées
et bien sûr on parle de muté quasiment
100 000 logements en disant c'est
considérable mais si on l'avait pas fait
ça veut dire qu'on laissait dépérir que
ça soit du logement social ou du
logement privé ces bâtiments c'est
extrêmement complexe
et c'est des bâtiments une bonne partie
de ces logements sont évidemment
occupés il y a deux questions qui se
posent c'est en effet d'une part les
techniques d'aujourd'hui par rapport à
des matériaux anciens et donc des
difficultés trouvées les bons types de
rénovation et la diminution des surfaces
et y compris c'est un des freins qu'on
voit aussi dans losmania très clairement
où il y a une interdiction de faire des
ravalement par l'extérieur et que tous
les propriétaires sont pas prêts à
diminuer leur surface locative ou leur
surface de logement
je pense qu'aujourd'hui en fait on a on
est très on est en très grande
difficulté alors comme on le contourne
bah quand il y a des bailleurs sociaux
typiquement dans le RBM on le contourne
pas ça c'est à dire que y compris il y a
beaucoup de programmes ont de deux
logements on en a fait un on a fait des
extensions on a encore fallait-il que
les PLU le permettent et puis aussi des
endroits on a fait des petits logements
alors il y a des endroits où ça
fonctionne très bien parce que la
demande est en petit logement mais ça
n'ira pas partout et en effet je pense
que c'est c'est une évidemment des
difficultés
des difficultés aujourd'hui très
clairement donc
je sais pas trop exactement comment
est-ce qu'on doit faire néanmoins je
note une chose c'est que dans
l'engagement pour le renouveau du bassin
minier on a fait un diagnostic très
poussé et notamment on avait cette
urgence à réhabiliter des dizaines de
milliers de logements alors porté par
plusieurs parieurs sociaux mais il y
avait aussi par deux bailleurs qui avait
des copros mais très clairement ces
données des engagements chiffrés avec
tout un débat budgétaire extrêmement
complexe qui a qui qui a pas été évident
mais quand même assez exigeant c'était
d'ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs une des
reproches qu'on m'avait fait c'est qu'en
gros ça ça allait trop loin ça engagé
trop et quinquennats suivants enfin moi
je crois au contraire on a bien fait de
le faire et qu'à un moment la puissance
publique dans certains secteurs elle
doit elle doit faire cela alors je le
dis parce que je pense que on peut pas
le faire pour tous les territoires vous
avez parlé de l'outre-mer et c'est
peut-être ça aussi qu'il faut qu'on
fasse sur certains territoires
d'outre-mer aujourd'hui on a des enjeux
considérables mais c'est aussi le sujet
de l'habitat insalubre et de ce qui
s'est passé à Marseille on va dire les
choses très franchement donc
je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait conscience
de ça la deuxième chose c'est de pas
laisser les gens tout seul très
clairement dans certains secteurs que
notamment de l'habitat qui va être porté
par des particuliers mais qui a été de
l'habitat avant social ou en tout cas
qui appartenait en fait je pense dans
tous les anciens industriels dans la
sidérurgie vous avez beaucoup de
logements qui sont aujourd'hui privés
mais qui est en fait avant était été ou
hier et aux différentes entreprises de
la sidérurgie si on n'aide pas les
particuliers ils y arriveront pas c'est
le coût et c'est ça en fait qui est
extrêmement compliqué
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on se raconte
des histoires sur le coup de la
rénovation alors nous-mêmes alors là je
parle pour le logement social on essaie
d'étudier ça je sais que Clana essaie de
produire des chiffres aujourd'hui sur
les coûts de la rénovation l'inflation
depuis 6 mois a changé totalement le
paradigme mais on est très souvent à
plus de 50 000 euros au logement je
pense qu'il faut avoir conscience de ça
par rapport à des biens qui souvent ont
une valeur qui est inférieure à 100.000
euros
et je pense que c'est une des
difficultés
et c'est pour ça que je vous parlais du
modèle économique au début parce que
qu'on soit modeste ou moins modeste la
question peut quand même se poser entre
la valeur de son bien et les travaux que
l'on va que l'on va y faire malgré des
aides très intéressantes le
l'ampleur de ma prime rénov et tout ça
et vraiment très intéressante mais on
voit bien quand même qu'il y a un reste
à charge considérable et avec des
ménages qui vont pas se réendetter en
plus si par ailleurs ils n'ont pas fini
de financer leurs biens donc je pense
aussi peut-être que si on avait un outil
statistique un peu plus performance qui
serait intéressant en tout cas nous
c'est ce qu'on a porté dans le cadre des
Assises de la construction
c'est qu'on puisse mieux renseigner le
coût des travaux le coût des matériaux
pour aussi comprendre les capacités les
capacités demain à faire et donc aussi
pour vous vous éclairer dans le débat
budgétaire
parce qu'en réalité
je ne suis pas sûre malgré tout ce qu'on
dit que les moyens budgétaires
d'aujourd'hui soient suffisants pour
tenir le rythme en tout cas de
l'éradication des clacher puis des
classes EF et EF pardon
en moins d'une minute madame la ministre
j'aimerais merci Madame la Président
j'aimerais avoir votre réaction sur un
point précis par rapport à ce que vous
venez dire je suis un vieil élu du
bassin minier donc depuis 40 ans je suis
membre d'un conseil municipal d'une
commune minière j'ai vu toutes
l'évolution on est passé de la dix mots
à la Soginorpa à l'épineur pas à
l'établissement public
donc tout ça tout ça je l'ai bien en
tête aujourd'hui vous venez de rappeler
deux chiffres à peu près 50000 euros
pour une rénovation thermique digne de
ce nom notamment sur les logements
individuels et même sur les jumelées et
sur des bâties qui ont une valeur
marchande qui est bien inférieure à
100000 euros ou aux alentours de 100000
euros lorsque les collectivités les
grandes collectivités région et les deux
départements se sont portés acquéreurs
du patrimoine minier en créant
l'établissement public et puis du repas
j'ai la faiblesse de penser que c'est
pas seulement les maisons qu'on
l'acheter c'est surtout la richesse
c'est le foncier et aujourd'hui avec le
0 artificialisation des sols je me
demande si la vraie force des élus qui
sont en responsabilité de l'épineur pas
elle ne réside pas en cela à savoir
optimiser parfois à certains endroits
sur certaines communes en accord avec
les élus locaux de procéder purement et
simplement à la démolition de certains
biens pour reconstruire des biens qui
sont parfois moins chers et qui sont à
la norme du point de vue thermique
alors monsieur le sénateur c'est une
question une question compliquée mais
qui m'appelle de réflexion d'une part
vous avez raison d'interroger sur la
question du foncier parce qu'en effet on
voit bien les mutations très rapides qui
s'exercent sur la le prix du foncier
alors qui sont pas nouvelles sur les
zones très constructives mais y compris
avec le zan je pense que l'évolution des
prix du foncier est assez considérable
et se pose la question se pose y compris
d'ailleurs les fonciers y compris des
collectivités locales dans pas mal
d'endroits qui est d'un seul coup
reprennent une valeur assez importante
et on pourrait d'ailleurs même se poser
la question en tout cas c'est des choses
qui sont étudiées aujourd'hui de voir si
on peut utiliser les techniques de
démembrement qu'on a développé en OSB RS
pour le logement social de voir si on
peut les utiliser pour faire du portage
soit pour des lots de copropriété
dégradées soit pour de la rénovation
c'est je vous dis pas qu'on sait le
faire on y réfléchit actuellement parce
que des collectivités locales ont
interrogé leurs organismes logements
social sur le sujet alors dans des
endroits pas évident puis ensuite il y a
la question de la démolition et je pense
qu'en effet
alors aujourd'hui on essaie plutôt de
peu démolir parce que la démolition
produit
des émissions carbone énorme
et qu'en fait toutes celles qu'on peut
éviter c'est essentiel mais notamment je
pense aux émissions carbone des
bâtiments construits dans les années
50-60 avec du béton parce que on parle
pas des mêmes émissions entre le béton
la pierre la brique etc et après il y a
la question y compris on est parfois mis
en discussion sur les démolitions dans
le cadre de la rénovation urbaine et on
pourrait en discuter dans le cadre du
bassin minier faut regarder aussi
pourquoi est-ce qu'on démolit des
bâtiments aujourd'hui soit parce qu'ils
posent des vrais problèmes urbains et
que les gens qui vivent ils vivent très
mal et je pense qu'il faut avoir
conscience de ça on a aussi construit
des trucs mais c'est juste un impensable
ce qu'on a pu construire parfois et
alors on peut réfléchir est-ce qu'on de
lui est-ce qu'on resture est-ce qu'on
démolit en partie et puis vous c'est
l'habitat individuel complètement
parcellaire et il y a deux sujets en
fait dans votre question et vous
connaissez je pense que vous connaissez
ma réponse et oui je pense qu'il y a des
endroits on peut démolir là où c'est pas
des sites classés
et que c'est pas du patrimoine UNESCO et
où il y a pas une qualité parce que tous
les bâtiments ne sont pas de bonne
qualité il y a quand même des bâtiments
il faut aussi interroger ça il y a des
bâtiments ou en fait les murs c'est
vraiment des des passoires en soi
et puis il y a des enjeux de
densification c'est à dire que
je on va sur un autre débat mais
aujourd'hui une ville qui émet moins une
ville une commune qui va veut réduire
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre
c'est aussi qu'elle se densifie
densifier ça va pas dire faire des des
tours c'est avoir un habitat y compris
individuel plus rapproché avoir des
distributions qui sont plus rapprochées
et donc rechanger les plans et c'est une
question qui peut se poser notamment
dans des territoires où les biens n'ont
aucune valeur y compris ou le coût de la
rénovation pour redonner un confort
d'habiter et était extrêmement cher et
vous voyez c'est pour ça que c'est
intéressant la décentralisation parce
que cette discussion elle est
intéressante si on l'a localement je dis
ça parce qu'en effet quand on a fait le
renouveau du bassin mini après un
diagnostic on a discuté pendant 6 mois
avec les agglomérations tout autour de
la table pour se poser les bonnes
questions les outils qui nous manquaient
etc et j'espère qu'on aura fini ce
programme dans 15 ans mais ça va être un
programme très long mais c'est aussi
pour ça que c'est intéressant parce que
je pense qu'il y a des sujets
objectivement c'est pas juste de savoir
à combien il a pris à combien est
l'emprunt et de savoir si on fait un
gain de une classe ou deux classes qui
va suffire et et
bah voilà le logement c'est c'est pas
que enfin c'est du vivant quoi donc je
pense que ça explique aussi parfois nos
difficultés parce que quand les
associations ou les ou les partenaires
des différentes politiques sont sur le
terrain en discussion avec un ménage
pour essayer de trouver la bonne
solution ben on se rend compte que c'est
extrêmement difficile pour trouver et
pour y aller et y compris qu'il faut un
dialogue avec les collectivités pour
aussi voir les enjeux urbains parce
qu'il y en aura après je vous cache pas
que partout où on peut éviter démolir
parce que le bâtiment a une qualité et
qu'en fait il peut être structuré ça
vaut le coup aujourd'hui parce que c'est
des coûts carbone évités mais je le dis
quand même comme il y a pas de marché
carbone et moi non mais moi en tant que
bailleur quand j'évite de démolir je
suis très contente pour l'enjeu par
rapport à la planète mais enfin je
calcule mon coût je calcule mes
émissions invitées j'en rencontre je
communique donc on est heureux mais
économiquement vous savez quoi je suis
même parfois moins aidé que si j'avais
démoli donc cette question quand même
elle se pose aujourd'hui je dis pas
qu'elle va changer tout sujet mais mais
ne pas vouloir s'attaquer à la question
de l'économie du carbone à mon avis
explique une partie de nos de nos freins
il y en a d'autres évidemment mais c'est
aussi une des explications
et bien merci beaucoup madame lacrimine
merci beaucoup plaisir à vous entendre
de nouveau en votre qualité de
présidente de l'USH et on vous souhaite
une bonne fin de journée merci